how does it feel to be here in San Luis
for the Third Edition of the Karen's cup
yeah I'm very happy I played first one
and after after a break we are playing
like third one and very happy to be part
of it it's the strongest tournament in
the world with huge price fun and I'm
really glad to be invited
um it feels good it's my first time in
us and in Saint Louis so I really love
the atmosphere and I really love the
venue so I do look forward to play as
soon as possible
well it's great I was actually surprised
when I got the invitation because for
the second tournament I I didn't and I
was really upset so when I saw the email
I was very happy and I I mean I told to
my parents like okay we're going to
sometimes again yeah I'm very excited
and I think this time it's a quite a
different field with lot of mix of egg
players as well and definitely this is
one of the strongest women tournaments
and also with the highest price fund
ever
so I think it's going to be quite tough
for everyone I'm so happy to be back
here I mean I'm so happy that the
Karen's cup has resumed after a couple
of years you know um of a break for the
for the pandemic and um yeah it's a very
special tournament I mean it was kind of
formulated to be one of the strongest
tournaments for women in the world and I
think it's going to be super exciting
I'm always very excited when I'm getting
invitation from Saint Louis and I'm
really very glad that I'm still here
after three years of break and yeah I'm
looking forward for a wonderful
tournament I'm really excited because
after three years we all are here and we
understood the value of it after
pandemic and to give importance that we
are here all healthy and playing the
tournament so definitely I'm really
excited that the strongest tournament
clearance cup is back with the Third
Edition and yeah I'm looking forward to
be part of it so it's a long time time I
have not been here it was 2018. my first
visit to Saint Louis and I had very good
Memoirs despite of my playing so I hope
I hope that this year will be more
interesting games for me and
um I think well very well here I'm
delighted to the time here because I
like this club very much and this
atmosphere everything it's
um it's really nice
it's over here again
um first of all like I was very happy to
receive the invitation almost in the
last moment because I think I was one of
the last participants to join the event
but yes I remember my time in 2019 even
so I think back this time I got the last
place not sure but I think so
um this time I hope I will do a lot
better I mean at least like to get
somewhere in the middle would be nice
and yes I am very happy
um that when I came here today that I
could recognize so many things so
nothing really changed and it's still
the same Spirit like looking at the hall
of fame
so I'm really excited to start actually
I'm very very happy and very excited I
was very looking forward to coming back
because we had this
um three year long Gap and you know
every single year we like got emails
about the possibility to be back and
then somebody didn't quite work our way
so I'm very relieved to be back and I'm
very looking forward to playing again
[Music]
thank you